last year policymakers were convinced
that inflation would be transitory
temporary that's a transitory thing but
over a year later I think I was wrong
then about the path that inflation
um would take for most of 2022 inflation
lingered above eight percent a 40-year
high
it's affected everything from gas prices
to groceries but why has it lasted
longer than many experts expected there
are a few key factors that propped it up
and made it tricky to predict what comes
next
the first is consumers have more to
spend at the beginning of the pandemic
emergency measures from Washington
including stimulus checks loan pauses
low borrowing costs and more flushed the
economy with cash and those resources
really built up and it was a large
stockpile of dry tender that was ready
to spend as the economy loosened up this
is the U.S
U-Haul saving rate the amount of money
households have left over after they
spend and pay taxes every month
this Spike and the ones that followed
contributed to 2.3 trillion dollars in
extra savings which is one of the
reasons consumers have continued to
spend as prices have gone up
there was pent-up demand humans are
social animals they wanted to go back
out to restaurants they wanted to see
their friends they wanted to visit
families it resulted in more spending
but it also resulted in companies
demanding higher prices
the FED estimated that there was still a
stock of 1.7 trillion dollars in excess
Savings in mid-2022
and as consumers have continued spending
companies have been hiring to meet that
demand there was just such a demand for
workers after the pandemic that
companies had a lot of openings for
positions that they just couldn't fill
in an environment of very low
unemployment here's a chart that helps
show just how strong the job market is
this is the number of job openings and
this is the number of people who are
unemployed on the one hand you have an
excess of demand from all the money in
household bank accounts and the other is
you have a deficit of Supply from
shortages of work not only workers but
also Goods sourced in Global Supply
chains to help try to fill those vacant
positions and encourage workers to stay
on businesses have also raised wages
compensation for private and state and
local government workers has grown by
five percent from last year but when
companies raise wages they often raise
prices to make up the difference as
wages go up companies respond by by
raising prices well as prices go up
people say my cost of living is going up
you got to increase my pay and this
process starts feeding on itself but
aside from consumer spending power and
the labor market inflation has just been
a really hard target to hit it's kind of
been like watching a game of
whack-a-mole every time you see
inflation pop up in one area and think
you understand it it puts its head down
and pops up in some other area price
increases have rippled through the
economy at different times in 2021
prices for things like groceries cars
and gas were pushed up by economic
recovery from the pandemic then in 2022
airline tickets Rose as well as the war
in Ukraine drove up the price of jet
fuel and to some of those prices started
to ease housing kept going up as the
economy reopened and rents increased so
inflation has run right through your
home from the stuff you put in your home
the televisions and the furniture the
actual cost of living in the home from
the good sector to the services sector
right there in your own day-to-day life
I think around
policies need to be enacted in order to
bring inflation down I just think that
the inflation picture has become more
and more challenging over the course of
this year without question that means
that we have to have policy be more
restrictive and that narrows the path to
a soft Landing it's using this
instrument that hits certain sectors of
the economy harder than others so it
raises interest rate which raises the
cost of interest in interest sensitive
sectors like housing but it might not
hit other parts of the economy where
inflation is acute the international
monetary fund says that interest rate
increases have their Peak effect on
inflation after three to four years
monetary policy has long and variable
lags which is another way of saying it
takes time for these effects to work
their way into the economy and the
backdrop to the economy is constantly
changing that's the variable part so it
takes time to play through and how it
plays through is unpredictable so the
story is still unfolding
the FED made another interest rate
increase at the beginning of November
and said that they may push interest
rates higher than originally expected